you rarely hear particularly early in  the game but they came back strong  they've had a couple of runs  dropped their corner led by trae young  who's had another  [Applause]  sensational game there's this smaller  lineup that charles wanted with  giannis rejected by cottonwood but a  foul  but he wanted giannis at the five where  you can switch everything  now the swipe happened down low right  there  and barking it's hard for them to tell  is he going to challenge it powell has  called on middleton  doubleton is upset his one goes to the  right didn't miss any time getting to  the following  yeah on the arm absolutely that's a foul  one who does not take time at the line  on the hop to middleton drives baseline  pops it out here's connorton for  three it's an air ball the save  attempted  [Applause]  tougher and then battered into the front  court